today lunch money is brought to you by
ftx us now ftx not only do they have
low low low low fees
but they also just launched stock
trading and the stock trading
they just bawling right here we're going
to talk about in a second but there's no
fees and there's no payment for order
flow so ftx us they will give you a
bunch of stuff if you go download ftx us
and
just use the link in the description
they have exclusive benefits those
benefits uh are starting to get pretty
good we're we're hammering on them we're
like i don't want to say people's name
over there but fda write you got to give
the audience more stuff if you don't
have an ftx account go get a ftx account
ftx us they've got stock trading now and
also uh obviously they've got bitcoin
cryptocurrencies etc they're integrating
the lightning network as well they're
working on that i don't know if you guys
saw they recently had uh brett the
president of ftx and elizabeth stark
from lightning labs doing a little call
with each other trying to figure out
what ftx
beat
other exchanges to integrate lightning
let's see
i don't know first topic elon musk let's
just talk about it
elon musk been voting democrat his whole
life
the man said he wants to buy twitter
preserve freedom of speech he says he's
going to vote republican and now they're
saying he's a sexual predator already it
took like two weeks for them to put out
the hit piece
business insider put it out
they seem to have a track record now
of
saying people
are doing nefarious things from a sexual
harassment standpoint what do you guys
think about this
i think uh well first off to your point
i agree that that that that is
directionally true but i also do i think
it's naive to think that elon didn't put
out those tweets in response to them
asking him for a comment on the article
one hundred percent he's trying to front
run he was from knowing that that's
already getting ready for hit pieces
like the next day it came out it's like
bro they already asked you for a comment
we know that you knew that already so i
don't think anyone thinks that he didn't
know that it was certainly people on the
internet that think he didn't that he
was like predicting it and then it
happened oh no no no no no i don't think
yeah which which i don't believe right i
think that he was uh front running it
for sure but i also think um
it it's just interesting right like
there's obviously a lot of things with
the story that people could question or
not uh but i think what ultimately is
happening now is people are going to be
put in this weird position where it's
going to become uh socially unacceptable
to support him in certain ways right
whether it's him acquiring twitter or
doing certain things and that's not
right or wrong it's just that's how
people are going to feel they're going
to feel like it's not socially
acceptable and i think that's a bad
thing i think i i so i agree that's what
they're going to try they being the
people writing the pieces like that
that's what cancel culture does right
when joe rogan got got cancelled if
you're a rogan fan all of a sudden
you're an idiot you're a racist you
support this guy like all this stuff and
everything but the way you break down
cancel culture is everyone literally
just says
we are not going to listen to this
nonsense we still support this person so
for example yeah andrew schultz yeah he
came out he goes dude i know this guy
for years he's not racist yeah right and
when he put the flag in the ground
then all of a sudden other comedians
started to come out and say it but like
i don't think andrew schultz probably
got the uh the credit he deserves for
being willing to go on record say it
publicly and be like and then he was
like calling out other comedians been
like this dude literally helps you build
your career and y'all gonna sit here and
be silenced by these fools right and i
think elon has such a big
following and such a big audience uh
that don't like the politicalization of
all this stuff and like the moralization
whatever uh that it's gonna be very hard
for them to cancel the richest man in
the world right now with that said
i don't know what happened
i don't you guys don't know what
happened and so like
the default
unfortunately for the media
is that immediately when somebody reads
this they like i had people text me
yesterday and they're like this is a
joke
right there's just no trust whatsoever
with the media i didn't even have to
read the article to to know what it said
i didn't i didn't know the story of the
settlement and all that but i saw the
headline i was like i know exactly what
narrative this article is going to push
it to a t it did a little bit better i
thought it was going to be complete
slander but it was more just like hey
like
we reached out for a comment like they
threw a few things in there to make it a
little bit i didn't even talk to the
woman that was the craziest part of it
of this specific one is that it's a
friend of a person that this supposedly
occurred with well that's my point
though that's the real shitty part is
that uh because obviously these things
do happen sometimes right and there are
important people wealthy people etc that
do these bad things and should
it should be shown light on right and
they they should get whatever comes if
you're a bad dude of course or a woman
and you do bad things you should be
expecting the fact now where uh business
insight or really any publication post
something like this online and
immediately a large percentage of people
whether it's 60 50 30 whatever a large
percentage of people automatically
assume that it's [ __ ] it's fake
they're they're grasping at straws etc
that's a problem i think that uh it
speaks to obviously the distrust in
media that we've seen but uh it's it's
obviously gotten worse over the last few
years so i think what we'll find out is
like let's let's see how uh how it
happens there's
especially with business insider uh if
anyone followed anything that happened
over the last few months with them and
dave portnoy and everything else like
there was some uh obviously
inconsistencies in their reporting that
were did dave portnoy and elon musk just
become best friends
probably
elon's probably gonna call him up and be
like let's take how did you get together
well i just i just looked it up and i
think that insider according to this
website again uh dun and bradstreet
pretty well respected uh firm they are
saying that uh
this can't be true insider only does 85
million dollars in sales
yeah you don't think that's true
i mean
elon literally like that spare change
he may just go buy insider yeah
right like 85 million 85 million dollars
in sales that's it
let's say that they i don't even know if
i should say this but the the the 250
000 payment that was like really really
weird let's talk about it that was like
way too small for something of this size
and skill like if you really think about
i don't i haven't looked at tesla stock
or any these other companies like
obviously some of them are private and
don't have mark to market but it's
billions of dollars hundreds of billions
of dollars that could be impacted by
something like this right a 250 000
payment is like
suspiciously small for something of this
large of a scale
yes i agree
i i think that and that doesn't mean
that it's not true right i just that's
something that stuck out to me of like
that's weird right if you know if this
is true and that's accurate [ __ ]
evidence or whatever it was yes then
that seems like a very small payment
yeah i agree john anything else
no i did read after the fact that uh
ndas are no longer allowed in california
um a few months after the after this was
already done they were already about
sexual harassment yeah sexual harassment
and like for these specific
types of cases you can't use nda's for
the uh settlement or severance or
whatever um because they want people to
talk about it i mean that's a pretty
crazy uh just for these types of cases
though every other case you can use an
nda yeah it's it's crazy i guess that
like different state well i guess the
states rights are yeah like they have
different rules around that stuff yeah
it was just interesting to see like this
happened right before it which
depending on whose side you're on is
good or bad so
what do we think forget for a second
whether the story is true or not we're
never going to be able to tell that
the impact though i think we can uh
pontificate on what do you think is uh
the likely impact of this two weeks from
now does anybody even remember this
article or do you think this is the
beginning of a snowball and there's more
of this stuff coming uh and he's gonna
be
he's now
risen to the point where every media
company's gonna attack him and try to
knock him down yeah look i i think like
uh there's some people that are just
blindly gonna say like elon didn't do
this he's great he's fantastic and i
certainly don't consider myself in that
boat like i don't know what he has and
hasn't done uh from an entrepreneurship
perspective i think he's incredible
right i think he's built a lot of good
companies i don't know if that's even
you can argue that at this point from
like a personal perspective it's
obviously a completely different story i
don't know him personally i don't know
what he does i don't know the type of
person he actually is so i think all of
that like you got to let it play out and
see if anything actually comes from it
but it wouldn't surprise me to your
point of just like how the media works
today
this is probably more likely to start
than it is of just like people are going
to forget it because of the incentive
and the reward for you to find these
stories for people to come and tell
these stories uh for for magazines and
newspapers and websites
yeah agreed the only thing i would add
was there's gonna be another story in a
week people are gonna move on bezos got
slander when he was coming up right when
people are successful they get slander
everyone has skeletons in their closet
maybe not to this extent but everyone is
nervous about something that they did in
the past coming up in the future um
yeah look there will be another story we
were talking about this morning the
world is very very good at moving on
with things very very quickly um you can
see everyone was really worried about
the canadian trucker situation two weeks
later you stopped hearing about it um
ukraine has and russia has died down
significantly what people are hearing
about it even though what's happening is
still going on so i just think the world
will it will move on and people will
move on to the next thing
all right next thing is uh
ftx now has uh stock trading
and what's fascinating to me about this
is ftx obviously is known as uh a crypto
company they you know 30 billion dollar
plus company uh and ftx is rolling out
in beta u.s customers will now be able
to trade cryptos stocks and nnfts from
one interface they have hundreds of u.s
exchange listed securities including
common stocks etfs uh and it's
integrated in their crypto trading
experience it's all in one place uh they
this is where it gets interesting they
provide transparent trade execution and
fair pricing they will initially route
all orders through nasdaq
they will not receive any payment for
order flow
and in a diff in addition fractional
shared trading will be available in
select securities
they're going to offer their customers
no fee brokerage accounts
commissionless trading
and free data and company fundamental
data
and then on top of that the company is
not using any minimum required customer
balances
tiered account systems
and
on top of all that
they are also going to the first time in
industry history have retail brokerage
accounts that can be funded with fiat
backed stable coins such as usdc
now when i think of all this i think of
plenty of people who did commission free
trading but it was all payment for order
flow
when ftx comes in and says hey we're
just going to offer stocks in the same
interface
no fees and no payment for order flow is
that the national end state like do is
just the competition driving everyone
there and then attack and trade all
digital uh assets whether it's stocks
whether it's crypto whatever all in one
place like this is what every single
platform could eventually do yeah i mean
some of them have already done that like
robin hood for example offers crypto not
that it's the best crypto platform but
there's some that offer stocks crypto et
cetera uh so i think that we're headed
that way to me it was it was a genius
move to come out and say hey look we're
not even we're not going to charge
commission but we're also not going to
do payment for order flow right the two
things that people hate and have given
people a hard time for over the last few
years so ftx can obviously subsidize
this with the big business that they've
built in crypto uh but other companies
aren't able to do that as easily without
raising a bunch of money and burning a
bunch of cash so they've now created
this moat that gives them the ability to
go sign up a bunch of new customers and
get a bunch of assets that they can
subsidize through their other products
which i think is really smart and then
the second thing is like
it's very uh interesting that this
happened a week after sam bankman freed
acquired a passive uh five six seven
percent stake in robin hood right
because it's it's obviously a similar
business they they built most of their
business on uh no fee trading no fee
stock trading now they do crypto and
other stuff but like now they're
starting to look kind of similar and uh
you wonder if at some point that passive
stake becomes active and you try
something
that used to be crazy but now is
probably not nearly as crazy that elon
has done stuff like this john ftx has
over a million users robin robin hood
has over 20 million users right if they
can onboard even a small percentage of
robinhood users and make them use the
ftx app instead and do all their crypto
trading and their stock trading there
it's a no-brainer sam beckman free
taking a stake in robin hood is a great
move for him i mean it's very popular
app with the younger generation a lot of
people are involved in crypto in the
younger generation it's good onboarding
flow for him and if he ever wanted he
could try to you know merge the
companies or anything like that but i
don't think we're going to get there
anytime soon
do you think he's going to try to take
over robin hood like it's a hostile
takeover dude i don't know how he's
going to do it i think he's going to buy
the business he's worth less than 9
billion i i 100
think he's going for it yeah
and i think that it's a genius thing to
do is he doing the elon playbook though
five percent move up again well he
bought seven
basically he had to disclose it right
over five percent i think you have to
disclose uh
but the more interesting part is if you
bought it do you just buy it and hold it
and just leave it there uh and let it
operate as it is or do you try to
integrate it and like
only one brand survives right and you
basically take all the uh robinhood
users bring them over to ftx and now you
just have ftx uh users and you jump from
1 million to 20 million i feel like uh
ftx out of a lot of the companies that
are out there today has probably done
the best job if not you know one of the
best jobs of becoming that like uh
whether it's crypto or stocks or
basically that that platform of like
that next generation of that next
culture right and robin hood represented
that for a long time actually people
give them a lot of [ __ ] now but that's
really how they built their business was
it was all uh you know 18 to 24 to 30
year olds on the app that we're doing
these commission free stock trades and
day trading basically tracking
everything it's true
we're we're laughing because i'm like
yeah that's john yeah i mean well
maybe it was at some point maybe it
still is but ultimately i think ftx is
moving into that thing and a lot of that
has to do with their marketing strategy
right they do these big events they do
these festivals they do the sports
arenas they do all this stuff make it
cool they make it cool exactly and if
you were to buy robin hood like that
basically just catapults you even
further into that that uh that site and
i think it's a big advantage for them
yeah one of the best things to do when
starting a company building a product is
make it cool yeah make it cool it will
survive yeah the other piece of it too i
think is that uh ftx obviously has this
massive business that they've got uh if
they could basically take robin hood uh
get rid of the payment for order flow
say that hey we came in and we got rid
of the payment for order flow
all of a sudden all those users but yo
we like this guy yeah right we like this
company um and so i think that they're
trying to do that by just saying hey
look we have a competitive offering
let's pull people uh but if they
actually went and bought it uh that that
would be fascinating the big question is
is it gonna keep falling the stock price
like it's worth nine billion now is it
actually on its way to three or is there
gonna be some recovery back the actual
price of the stock is not under ten
dollars under ten dollars now and i
think it ipoded at like 40 bucks 8.6
billion 8.6 like like if it gets under
five billion yeah
sam may be able to just buy with cash
right like like robert falls to five
billion there's literally a chance that
sam bakeman freeze she was like i'm
saying someone calls usdc your company's
worth 4 billion someone comes and goes i
got 5 billion cash let's do it and you
reject that offer
yeah he would have to do a premium
whatever right so like i may be a
traditional
takeover but also what would be
fascinating is if they keep if he keeps
buying up stock and we go from seven to
like 15 to 20 percent and it becomes
hostile
fireworks
i don't i don't put as much uh weight on
it happening as maybe you guys do
yeah i don't i mean he said it's not
gonna happen right so you have to assume
that he's at least uh telling the truth
right now until he shows otherwise
but uh
i wouldn't be surprised right there's
just too many similarities between the
two businesses especially with what
they're doing now from a stock
perspective but also you have to think
about robinhood how cheap it's got right
it's well below its ipo price ran right
now the fundamentals of the business you
would assume are still pretty strong i
mean john said they have over 20 million
users uh the problem is though that i
believe a lot of their revenue was
coming from crypto when the bull market
was uh really running up and when that
stuff starts to fade then you get in
this weird position where like you're
still doing the payment for order flow
and people are paying you for that but
they were making the majority of their
money off crypto and specifically not
just like bitcoin and ethereum it was
off all these long tail assets that
people were day trading and if those
things all go away then you're in a
really difficult position if you're
robin hood because you have this massive
user base but you're not monetizing them
correctly because you were basically
taking the easy way out and monetizing
them through uh these super expensive
crypto trades and ftx if you're able to
subsidize that that's like a way out for
them right and if you can you know your
business is sitting at three four five
billion dollars eventually and they come
in and they offer you three four five
times that like your shareholders that's
something to think about right that's
obviously a pretty decent offer and
something that ftx would probably be not
only willing to do but could do and i
think that that when you consider all
three or four of those things like
starts to make more sense even though he
has said that it's not gonna happen yeah
but ftx saw something similar right with
uh popularity of app usage when crypto
was absolutely skyrocketing last year i
was looking at the numbers and robin
hood reported revenue of q2 last year
when bitcoin and all other
cryptocurrencies were on that bull run
they reported revenue of 233 million
dollars attributed to their crypto
accounts and then
this uh q1 of this year it was only
around 50 million so it got cut um by
down to like 25 of what it was or less
than 25 of what it was uh which is kind
of like fascinating to think that how
much popularity crypto has during the
bull runs and how people just stray away
from it during the uh during the bear
markets yeah so i i i'm pulling up these
stats right now of robin hood and how
much money they were actually making on
uh crypto if this would load we got some
uh some janky old wi-fi over here it
seems bro don't be starting with the
wi-fi complaints i'm just saying hey
johnny look it's not loading uh
let me see maybe i can just read it from
here i got you
ah
[Music]
basically in quarter to quarter when
when uh crypto assets last year in q3
dropped they saw uh what i i believe was
specifically
yeah so robinhood brought in 233 million
dollars in crypto revenue and q2 of last
year it was more than their options and
equities departments combined but 61 of
that 233 million dollars came solely
from dogecoin
61 of 200 so when when dogecoin dropped
the bonds robin hood saw its crypto
revenue dropped 78 percent from q2 to q3
and the stock went 50 down right and
it's the whole idea i wrote at the end
lived by the meme die by the meme and
it's like if you're true if you're
building your business on those things
and you're touting all this revenue and
you're making much money from it like
that's not sustainable really do they
time the ipo perfectly from an insider's
perspective
probably yeah they got out at the top of
the market
got public
and then it was just because what was
the business worth it was like 30
billion or something right yeah stock
price was in the stock price like 40 50
bucks yeah it ipoded 35 bucks yeah i
built it 35 it ran up a little bit so if
it's at eight right yeah 30 30 billion
probably yeah
and going right into a bull market yeah
yeah all those things and then look by
the way a lot of the drawdown of that
particular company isn't just because of
uh bad performance right some of it is
yes the financial performance changes
because people aren't you know uh uh
investing as much but also the market
changes compressed
all right crypto retirements uh
what what are you guys seeing with
people putting crypto in their
retirement accounts
i own uh gbtc in my retirement account i
mean let's talk about it the uh what's
the difference it's not looking too good
i do as well
gbtc is what i see
i got you is it minus 30 minus 30. yeah
29.4
getting crushed you guys nervous over
here that's why you shouldn't take
financial advice from me over here i'm
sitting with gbtc in the uh in the
retirement account just getting crushed
right now but i'm gonna hold it gbtc
keep saying that the spot etf's coming
they're gonna get converted they're
gonna get it i could hold longer than
the discount can persist all right
that's what i'm saying yeah it's a
retirement count
i got 30 years how long that discount
got
me that discount we just staring at each
other every day i'm i ain't changing dog
yeah you're going to go back here i'm
changing i'm going down
well that was my uh
let's go let's convert this bad boy
you're waiting
that was my uh my whole thing right like
most people would be super pissed off
about it right now but it almost makes
you want to buy more because you're like
wow the [ __ ] discount is at 30 if
this thing eventually gets converted and
bitcoin does what you think it's gonna
do then like that's a no-brainer trade
uh but those two things have to happen
right bitcoin obviously has to
appreciate and it has to get converted
to an etf the conversion so just so
people uh maybe to help people
understand this so uh gbtc uh
historically uh has been the grayscale
bitcoin trust trust being a key word
there because it is a trust and what a
trust means is the publicly traded trust
and the way that money gets into the
trust is that people would go to
grayscale the company behind it and they
would say hey i would like to invest in
your uh investment vehicle and so what
they would send you is documents you
would give them money uh and they would
take your dollars and they would say
okay in exchange for i'll make up a
number uh in exchange for a hundred
thousand dollars you get a hundred
thousand shares and it was trading at
let's say one dollar a share they take
your hundred thousand dollars and they
go buy bitcoin in the market that
bitcoin then sits inside of the
grayscale bitcoin trust so i've spent a
hundred thousand dollars or invested a
hundred thousand dollars i have a
hundred thousand shares at one dollar
in order
to get this private deal where it was
when it wasn't trading at one dollar
i have to hold those shares for six
months and one day i cannot sell them
for six months
so i get my hundred thousand shares when
i hold it
and the reason why i was willing to give
greyscale the money the hundred thousand
dollars for 100 000 shares was because
historically
the shares in the public market were
trading at let's call it a 15 to 20
premium so if i bought the shares for
one dollar
usually at that same exact moment they
were trading at a dollar 20 let's say
for easy numbers so i buy them for a
dollar in the private market i have to
hold for six months and then i sell them
for a dollar twenty
now if bitcoin's price goes up or down
that 20
premium
stuck it went down sometimes to 10 or 12
percent sometimes it went up to 25 30
but let's just call it 20
so there was a gbtc arbitrage and what
people would do lots of hedge funds and
big investors is they would go give
their money to grayscale in the private
placement they would get the shares
they'd hold for six months and on six
months in one day they would sell them
in the public market and they would
capture the premium and so usually that
was let's call it twenty percent well if
you do that after six months you get a
20 premium that's actually a 40
annualized return and so they would then
after they sell it take the cash and go
and do it again and they kept doing this
game over and over again well that's
amazing when there's a premium because
it pulls in a bunch of money into the
private market now what's unique about a
trust structure is that there is no
redemptions what that means is if you
give them the money and they go by the
bitcoin that bitcoin goes into the fund
there's no way to get the bitcoin out of
the fund so the if you are a shareholder
of the grayscale bitcoin trust the only
way to not hold the shares anymore you
can't show up and say hey give me the
bitcoin instead you have to sell the
shares to somebody else in the public
market
so if you wanted to buy gbtc in uh a
retirement council like that you could
have just gone in the public market went
to ticker gbtc bought it and then you'd
be holding those shares you also could
have
participated in the private placement
now where things got weird is that one
almost all or a very major portion
of the bull market from 10 000
of bitcoin in q3 into q4 of 2020
all the way up to 64 000
in march
and kind of april time frame of 2021
remember when it went from 10 000 broke
20 000 hit 30 000 right around the turn
of the year and accelerate always 64 000
a very large percentage of that move was
due to the gbtc arbitrage because what
was happening was there was so much
money flowing into that fund and they
were turning around they were buying so
much bitcoin on the market at one point
grayscale was buying
more than 100
of the daily incoming bitcoin supply so
at that time there's 1800 bitcoin coming
into the market every single day
grayscale was buying more than 1800
or 1800 bitcoin so as they're buying
more bitcoins coming into the market
naturally they're soaking up all of this
supply and then because there's no
redemptions the bitcoin can't come out
of the uh fund so now what ends up
happening is grayscale just became this
black hole for bitcoin it became like
the ultimate hodler and i believe that
it got up to like three percent of the
circulating supply was in that grayscale
fund and so three percent of the
circulating supply bam held no one's
gonna let go of it
uh because it is in a fund where there's
no redemptions
and there was an incentive the premium
for more and more people to keep
investing which meant that they could go
buy more bitcoin which meant they were
taking more bitcoin off the market and
they were holding it as they made the
market illiquid more people started to
come in because price was rising and it
accelerated all up to 64 000.
now the problem became
at some point that premium flipped to a
discount
and what we mean by premium and discount
is let's say that there's 10 bitcoin
trading in the um uh there's 10 bitcoin
in the fund and those 10 bitcoin are
each worth a hundred dollars so i'd be a
thousand dollar nav or or value in the
fund
if the collective value of the shares
was trading at twelve hundred dollars
that would be a twenty percent premium
of the share price to nav there's only a
thousand dollars worth of value in the
fund but it's trading at 1200 total
market cap and therefore the 20 premium
what occurred at some point is that
actually it went to a discount which
meant that that thousand dollars of
bitcoin that's sitting in there right
now it's at a 30 discount that would
mean that actually it's only trading at
700 if you take all the share prices or
all the shares and add it up uh and then
times it by the share price so you have
a thousand dollars in the fund but it's
only trading at seven hundred dollars
and so ultimately if you are somebody
who was holding gbtc
when it was at a thousand dollars
uh of value and at twelve hundred
dollars of market cap
that meant that you went from a 20
premium to now you're holding at a 30
discount even if bitcoin's price stayed
the same it is a very significant
impairment to the value of what you're
holding
and so people say well how do we get
back to nav right or how do we get back
so the share price ends up being
equivalent to the value in the um
in the actual fund so if you think about
that if it's at 700
now but really there's a thousand
dollars worth of value if it goes back
up that'd be almost 50 percent
increase in the price of the stock just
to get back to nav right obviously if
you go from 700 to a thousand uh just
under 50
and so the only path to that at the
moment
uh or viable path maybe that that seems
realistic is to convert the gbtc
grayscale bitcoin trust to
an etf now the reason why an etf is
interesting is because an exchange
traded fund has the ability to create
and redeem and so there's the ability to
go back and forth which means that you
don't have 20 premiums and 30 discounts
you get much much closer to nav and
there still might be you know plus one
plus uh negative one uh on on nav but
you don't get these massive premiums and
discounts because there's the ability to
redeem uh the actual assets themselves
so if you bought right now for example
if you went in and you bought the share
price at 30 discount to nav and you
could redeem you would go buy the share
turn around say hey give me the value of
my shares and you would get the 50
increase so it pushes the share price
back up to about nav
the question is when and if
grayscale's gonna be able to convert
this so what we're talking about is
i got forever it's in my retirement
account i'm not i'm just never gonna
sell it i'm just gonna wait till they
convert it because it's basically got a
baked in at this point from here it's
got a baked in return if they get the
conversion done that historically these
things go back to nav if that was to
occur then there would be value now
everything we just said one not
financial advice but also two that's
using what's previously happened in
these scenarios as a proxy for what is
expected to happen
but in today's marketing environment who
knows what occurs right
that's the exact way i think about it i
got time just hold yeah is that what
you're thinking john no i'm not gbtc
holder oh you got none yeah yeah i got
no gp
you died
pumped right now if it's [ __ ] if it's
down thirty percent
i have to get some now it sounds like
you guys are just holding forever so
in the retirement account why not i i
just got uh
diamond hands yeah yeah that's the best
meme that's the best movie it's like
when the guy's walking he's just shaking
his hands i would stop doing that on
camera this year was behind the computer
he couldn't see everyone ever it was
of the guy doing the flag no you've
never seen the one with the guy the cop
doing the flag at the football game and
you can't see his hands
god i'll look it up later nah i'm about
to look it up right now next thing
pharma bro
uh what what's this guy's name martin
charlie marge shrelly martin shelley
he's out he took the price of believe
insulin for uh up like 5 000 right
so i don't know all the details of why
he got in trouble we got in trouble my
guess is that it didn't help that he was
uh uh super abrasive what what
should be the meme he was talking about
all right
good meme uh martin shirelle is now out
of uh out of prison yeah
um i don't even know why this is news
other than like he became well known as
pharma bro which was like an all-time
nickname for him uh and he gets released
from prison the same day that uh the
fire festival guy
billy mcfarland
everyone better be careful online there
might be some scams going around online
y'all gotta watch your pockets silly was
doing stuff from behind prison walls
yeah podcast
they're like bro using the prison phone
to record a podcast he's like yeah no he
did not he had a podcast he would
release one one a week right because
when he would do the podcast they would
find out they would throw him in
solitary confinement he would get out in
a week and he would do another podcast
and get thrown back in i mean was it
popular was he making cash i don't know
i'm sure i mean i heard about it so i'm
sure some people spend a week in salt it
can find me i'm sure you're making some
money i i mean i like talking to people
and recording the episodes but i don't
think i'd trade solitary confinement for
a week you're getting a collect call
from billy mcfarland
all right so uh what do we think about
pharma bro he's on bumble how
what yeah he's on the dating apps
he's probably he's probably interested
it can't be real it can't be real though
not like it is i mean the the photos of
him getting out that he's posting online
from the car were real i think he's like
having fun with it i don't know i mean
he's a meme at this point right he just
got out of jail so i'm sure he's having
a little bit of fun
does he become a wolf of wall street uh
kind of like that's where that's his
place in the game now
yeah i don't know like wolf of wall
street i mean that guy is doing all
kinds of jordan belfort yeah speaking
tour
40 grand
to come to his house and teach people
i'm not gonna start i don't
i mean is that what uh shirelli uh shrek
rally uh is that his uh if he can
convince someone to come to his house
and pay him 40 grand to teach him should
we get him on this show we should yeah
i'd probably bring one let's ask i would
love to talk to him
i would love to understand what he says
that's not real
that's him bro looks like he's still in
the jumpsuit
he's really because he's really on
bumble already is that a verified badge
does that bubble work i don't know that
blue thing it's a little blue thing yeah
and why
man i i don't even know where to uh
somebody said he's the next tinder
swindler
did y'all watch that no did you yeah i
watched part of it yeah it was most of
it uh
yeah i mean the guys
guys is reckless he was doing all kinds
of crazy like what
basically his thing was he would like
find these girls on on an app he'd meet
up with them and they would think he's
like super super super wealthy like he
came from money and all this stuff
because he would meet them at these
expensive hotels he'd be driving
expensive cars he had security and all
this stuff and then he would start
dating them for a couple months he would
travel all the time so he'd see them
occasionally and whatever but he would
always talk to them and then they'd get
to a point like months later and he'd be
like uh hey someone's his business was
diamonds or whatever so he'd pretend
like you were always after him like he
was always scared he had security and
all this stuff so be like hey my credit
card's got frozen like i need you to
wire me money and he'd live this
expensive lifestyle so he'd be like i
need like a hundred grand and they'd be
like people would take out lines of
clothing so he would convince him to
take out lines of credit because he
would be like dating them for like six
months at this point they think they're
like getting married or eight months so
like you know so they would take out
like loans they would do all these
things they'd mortgage their house like
uh uh put their house up and all this
stuff so he'd get like hundreds of
thousands of dollars from people and
then he just stopped talking to them
and that is not real and he would do
this and the reason why he was able to
do it that was he would meet multiple
women and do it all at the same time so
he would use one person's money to fund
the next girl right to like take her on
trips and do all these things
yeah he was basically just using the
money that worked yeah well they're not
investors so i don't know if you call
that a ponzi scheme but i mean
that's basically what happened i haven't
been in the dayton game for a while
but if i was dating somebody and they
were like yo could you
take out a loan
and send me a hundred grand
i'd have a lot of questions i'm saying
what i'm saying we're not dating no more
yeah yeah just like i got a lot of
questions there well um i don't know
love it love uh i guess blinds you right
i guess man i i'm scared for anything so
i don't know
my guess is that he's actually going to
come back with a company i'm not going
to let anyone that says he's going to
give him money
no he has money how much money he got
you got a wu-tang album that was worth
like two million bucks right now oh you
had a seller yeah yeah all right so he's
out of that
oh that was like two million dollars
right he said i'm gonna buy and then
release it to the world
you're not allowed to do that
i do whatever i want when i'm the owner
uh let's see martin schreckerelli's net
worth yeah i say he's worth 70 million
i don't know isn't the kind of same
thing with uh uh
i mean it's based on some company uh
yeah they claim that that's his uh pro
no way that guy's worth 70 million
dollars oh they're saying now it might
be worse oh now they're saying it's zero
yeah there's no way it was 70 million i
had to pay a bunch i forgot a dow bought
the wu tang clan album oh yeah yeah yeah
74 member dow bought the wu-tang album
that was worth like two million dollars
yeah all right i'm gonna start like
releasing products and just only selling
the dows they all got too much cash they
need to part with and you know how much
cash they have too yeah they tell you
what products are you guys going to
create oh let's find a let's make an
album do you want to know what this is
they're buying albums do you want to
know a business that i think somebody
should create right now if somebody
wants to create this business i would
love for you to reach out to us uh i
would be very interested in starting
this
an american
furniture brand
that
just start like the way i would start
the business just start with wood tables
just create nice
wood tables
like a dinner table that you could
replicate over and over and over again
right now there's a huge furniture
shortage across america supply chains
are all screwed up all this stuff if you
could get the unit economics down
to be able to create
american-made
wood tables
and if you can sell them at a high price
point
i think you could make an absolute bag
like you could literally in
90 to 120 days i think we had a million
dollars uh in annual revenue well
there's a shortage for a reason
of course
right so what are you going to like is
lumber still he's going to sell a bunch
and then not deliver the table no no
what you do is you go and you source the
wood you i mean you do the work to get
all this stuff right
i assume there's a reason why there's a
shortage though because
most of the furniture is actually made
elsewhere and the supply chain
disruptions of getting it here now
obviously the price of lumber went up
right at one point but it's come down
significantly yeah it's at 6 16. are you
pitching ikea for america
i mean yeah they got great yeah i mean
you all know ikea turnout they turn out
money they're and uh furniture they're
selling people are saying the amish do
it like i'll compete with the amish
well maybe they'll they'll go in
business with us yeah or or we could be
worried amish come on listen either
you're our partner or you die at the
feet of our yeah
you're either in on it with us or you're
dead
you either are part of our business or
we crush you
yeah there are going to be no [ __ ]
furniture brands left
everyone's just going to walk in and be
like oh that table that table definitely
the pomp's made that
uh yeah look people said uh we bought an
american-made couch for our new house
jamie hall smith said this it took 10
months to get here they said the amis
can build a house in six days if they
can do it at six we can do it in five
tell them to hit us up
we're interested in their in their work
right yeah i mean people are literally
they're saying yeah like the the uh i
can get a handmade table that's made
locally right down the road your local
furniture shops will have plenty of
tables no we don't want uh that patrick
bailey we don't want people to go down
the street they got to come buy the
tables from us and we'll ship them to
you yeah we'll create a nice little
slick website we'll have people uh you
can put the picture of the furniture in
your house you know you upload the
picture we'll do that we'll be a data
company we'll raise money at 12 times
revenue and we'll do exactly somebody
said somebody said just resell the amish
furniture
we'll do exactly what markup we'll do
exactly what amazon does too and remove
all the negative reviews for their
products i think that we literally
should find
an entrepreneur who wants to do this
with us and i'll fund it we'll start the
business and we'll document
and i bet you that in 120 days we could
get to a million dollar run rate
four months 120
uh 120 days million dollar run rate i
think that's definitely possible
and all we do is we make one thing we
make american-made wood tables if you
ain't got one you're a loser
the marketing is about to be fire
i agree bunch of bald eagles american
flags
yeah and if you pay us double we'll
inscribe the table for you oh yeah
that's a good question do we do chairs
too or no no buy your own chairs br it's
byoc figure out what you're good at and
do that yeah byoc that's what type of
company we have byoc bring your own
chairs no one's trying to sit in a wood
chair either
well some people like wood chairs i
don't the wood tables i'm telling you
wood making wood tables right now would
pop
someone hit us up let's go if you can
make wood tables hit us up if somebody
knows how to do it
and we dm
how to make tables in here
we gotta uh
we we got to be able to do it at scale
too somebody's gonna drop the ship use
cedar garden boxes
no we're being serious
if somebody uh if somebody knows how to
mark's gonna help us design the tables
in the website yeah see see people are
saying so we gotta we gotta we got a
creative director
yeah i feel like i mean look i'm not
this ain't my day job but i feel like
tables are pretty easy
do you guys see i thought about this i
had little legitimately i was at a
restaurant and uh i was talking with a
couple of people and they were talking
about how uh there's this furniture
shortage the supply chains all the stuff
and i was thinking myself i'm like
tables
can't be that hard again maybe a [ __ ]
but like they can't be that hard to
build and you can probably build a
system where you can just churn them out
people will pay ridiculous price if you
google right now i mean look at this
ready nice wood uh dinner table how much
do you think they are three grand
fifteen hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty nine hundred fifteen hundred
eighteen hundred dollars people pay a
bag for tables it don't cost three
thousand dollars to make this table this
table looks like we made it oh we're if
we're not if we're not like that table
it looks like we made it we're not a
three figure business we're four figures
and higher a thousand bucks or higher on
this table no five thousand dollar nice
ass wood table you already know the
price of that anything else what if it
costs three grand to make
then it's 5 000 or more well it's gonna
have to be more now we need better
margins
you know how many ballers are out there
that would say i want to have a ten
thousand dollar table in my house and
and have it as like a talking point
yeah i agree a hundred tables ten
thousand dollars do the math
hey and uh if we sell them for a
thousand that means we gotta sell ten
times more so let's do ten grand i like
that people are saying palm how will you
get the wood i'll go to the forest
that's how i get the wood if there's a
shortage
we'll do is we'll buy some land that has
the wood on it and then we'll own the
land too no no no no you guys shouldn't
make this too complicated what i'm gonna
do
i legitimately think we should do this i
will go to the local lumber yard and you
know what i would say to them i say yo
local lumber yard hey how's your
business doing right now you know what
they'll probably say we were balling six
months ago when lumber was triple the
price or double the price or whatever it
is now but
we're still trying to figure things out
right and what i would say to him i said
i'll do a deal with you
you give me the wood at a good price
i'll cut you in to the upside
and
we'll throw in a bunch of free marketing
for you
so that we drive you more business you
get upside in our business there ain't
many people showing up there most people
showing up to say give me the wood for
cheaper we're saying we're gonna help
you make more money
and
we'll go ahead and we'll include them in
all the marketing of the tables and i
bet you we get whatever would we need
i uh i think we should do it i think
someone should hit us up to do it we
should see if we can get to uh whatever
your timeline was for a million dollars
to run rate uh and then
uh
maybe this is overstepping but if we do
it we give away all the money
i would do that yeah you looked at me
like what
now i got you all and we go give away
the money if we hit it if we do if we do
it all right hold on this is sir now my
really if you all are giving away the
money i'm out
here every time you're perfect perfect
see how that goes you ain't on the team
you done perfect yeah you gonna go do
join the amish team no i'm gonna go
build my own [ __ ] metal table
last longer good luck way better durable
i think i would do that the first
million dollars oh he said this has to
be the low point of the market i was
talking about tables this is business
we're talking about yeah this is what i
do i would create a table business and
the first million dollars of profit we
give away
to you all oh if you're watching
percentage i want upside oh no and i
wasn't saying whatever yeah we can talk
about the details later but uh we get to
a million dollars a run rate whatever we
make on that money we give away on the
show okay i would do it that way yeah
whatever we make we get it so you know
how to make tables
preferably in miami but if you know how
to make wood tables and you're and
you're good at it i don't want to need
y'all making uh basically tables held
together with elmer's glue
need real tables
yeah we don't hold cash on our balance
sheet just bitcoin
yeah of course what
uh all right last thing monkey pox man
this show's taking way longer than i
thought i was gonna take uh yeah i got
something to do at 12 30 fyi
we're gonna be done in ten minutes i've
got a couple calls i'm not playing
monkey pox what is it i'm not playing
with this monkey pox yeah i thought this
is making a [ __ ]
union
he's coming out he's like yeah let's do
another one i thought monkey i saw like
no
he just got over the last one i thought
monkey pox was hold on hold on hold on
just so that was a joke that's nice
hold on hold on hold on hold on
let's just make sure we're all on the
same page according to the cdc
obviously the uh uh center for disease
control and prevention the highest
quality provider of information in
society
monkey pox was first discovered in 1958
when two outbreaks of a pox-like disease
occurred in colonies of monkeys kept for
research hence the name monkey pox the
first human case of monkey monkey pox
was recorded in 1970 in the democratic
republic of congo during a period of
intensified effort to eliminate smallpox
since then monkey pox has been reported
in humans and other central and western
african countries
we then go look monkey pox is a rare
disease that is caused by infection with
monkey pox virus
monkey pox virus belongs to oh i can't
pronounce all those words
that means monkey pox was first
discovered in 1958 monkey pox cases and
people have occurred outside of africa
linked to international travel or
imported animals including cases in the
united states as well as israel
singapore and the united kingdom the
natural reservoir of monkey pox remains
unknown however african rodents and
non-human primates like monkeys may
harbor the virus and infect people
now i'm not playing with this because
the other thing that's really important
here yeah they bought millions of doses
of monkey pox vaccine after there was a
case confirmed in massachusetts health
officials currently investigating a
second potential case in new york city
now the way that this is transmitted
is when a person comes into contact with
the virus from an animal a human or
materials contaminated with the virus
and then the signs or the symptoms
according to cnn another great provider
of information in our society
is
that uh
let's see here
they claim
the initial symptoms
there's an incubation period of some 7
to 14 days according to the cdc initial
symptoms are typically flu-like such as
fever chills exhaustion headache and
muscle weakness followed by swelling in
the lymph nodes which help the body
fight infection and disease next comes a
widespread rash on the face and body
including inside the mouth on the palms
of the hand and the soles of the feet
the painful raised boxes are pearly and
fluid-filled often surrounded by red
circles the lesions finally scab over
and resolve over a period of two to
three weeks according to the cdc
treatment is generally supportive as
there are no specific drugs available
however a vaccine is available that can
be given to people
to prevent the development of diseases
i'm out
i'm out of all this
viruses i'm out
the maybe we have a case maybe we don't
in new york city
i'm out
i don't know why it feels like this
happening more maybe it's just because
we have dumb brains and now we're all
like super sensitive to it
but if there was a monkey pox
pandemic
that'd be bad um
with the lesions all over their body i'm
gonna take my thinking on this off one
line from the world health organization
that says monkey pox is less contagious
in smallpox and causes less severe
illness
i'm not really worried about it at this
point in time based off that comment
do you just you just good well uh
smallpox aren't uh
very prevalent in um i think that's
because people are vaccinated against
smallpox right
i don't know i don't know how i'm not
working i'm not i'm not a doctor i'm i'm
almost out of monkey pox you're out yeah
yeah i'm out but not worried
is that fair
john are you in on monkey
being out on monkey box i'm just i'm not
i'm just talking about it
no like i just i'm not going to be
keeping a bird's eye view on it or no
i'm just gonna not participate yeah me
too yeah i'm on that side yeah if monkey
pox comes and knocks on the door like
i'm not participating
no thank you
i'm out no thank you no soliciting yeah
yeah just go just go to the neighbors
you're good hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time